out of all the games coming out this III
it seems the one everyone is most
excited for Marvel's spider-man for
PlayStation 4
I'm Greg Alba Tony Gill so it's in the
gamer on Twitch Andrew there you in the
middle finger Cyberman pose you I use
one finger about is to I do music I give
you one movie stars channel on YouTube
egg or 7-eleven hey enough being around
the bush I wore Marvel shirt / risen hey
it's the star of spider-man homecoming
every minefield mother maybe more we're
both the same man here we go guys oops
I love the spider-man game I actually
really enjoy playing hi my name is sue
ever since that 64 units all units
there's a thirty six o'clock all units
be advised shots fire too many feathers
my god
No
[Music]
like my tire
[Music]
I'm here I'm here
what do you want what we did the demons
are moving in on sister territory blue
food okay oh [ __ ] I'm sure a lot it was
actual games like all this it's like
that like stealth mode nice yeah off
like my mother like predator mode yeah
yeah I'm just helping me to fight oh wow
and nice yes yes you literally swing
them up and hang them around you and the
blend of gameplay would like [ __ ] like
notice it's not like cutting enough it's
just all more if you don't see what yeah
territory powers down not today
now spider-man tell me I love his eyes
so able to figure it out - boom here we
go
and Wow yeah hye-rin
oh my god Wow stuff into the wallet it's
a little bit like Arkham Knight
instrument and it has some combat
similar he got the combat was it not a
bad thing - no no no
hey Willie dude
swing weight latinas who's their leader
[Music]
I love it oh man - feelin but you better
get your mother bad guys not sure I
thought today would go wow let's talk
about open world New York there's gonna
let go else burning head murdering
[Music]
god I love my hackers tags my like a
martial artist it was like a device
yeah I love that never use a cavity
actually right on the link in the clown
Bibble I'll do it as a fan of like a
martial arts a good manner vessel
business it runs the demons you're about
to find out
check the roof here
Wow giving spider-man
[Music]
you
[Music]
becoming out
by saving
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
come on man well I guess the latest are
captures Wow oh my god I'm good there's
Squatch emoji right go Spidey
[Music]
rate is determined by how they turned
out morning Li is wanting the demon
[Music]
it's like you - amazing - amazing
spider-man 3 Detroit oh because you need
to break it down okay no we're here a
little faster
working up here
[Music]
again
like our target Rihan press triangle
whole like one shot I know after the
baby actually isn't willing to do that
curve engineering or neither building
[Music]
tension a seat
[Music]
hi
[Music]
why are you doing it
[Music]
triangle
[Music]
[Music]
- Artu
[Music]
let's look at what we have Wow Oh like
cinematic movie that's I read the game
way like cinema close
[Music]
gives you like everything you want I've
been the senior vote mr. Lee
[Music]
and next year wow that's uh oh let's go
what I wanna have the cool matter I'd
like vintage Marvel you directly I can
make shoveling in briefs with it is when
that was that was amazing I mean I love
the like house colleagues is one long
tracking shot but like you said when we
were watching it's not to center the
whole time base yeah they even switch up
the angles even though it feels like
there's one long tracking shot
throughout it does switch to positioning
where the camera angle is that those
wildly impressive like they thought
about what everything spider-man can do
and let's have him do all those things
you said that was amazing I thought I
said this Jane designers of this got
like the blueprints for all the
architectural designs of every aspect of
New York City in just through in this
game going to any of the older
spider-man one of my favorite was a
fighter man the movie to they could made
was not enough amazing spider-man 100
the time input PlayStation 2 yeah yeah
well I was like one of my favorite
because they really got like a great map
of New York City and the webbing is
always be getting better and better for
a lot of these um yeah yeah but this one
just felt so fluent like at times when
you need to go fast you're not just like
shooting a web up into the like sky like
you said before you're actually shooting
at targets for PlayStation I got one
point I'm on saying like man this feels
like you're playing and charge it too
because our charges just like the whole
series because that's like a video game
movie where yeah the right way good
reference if you play it the right way
it feels like um damn you're watching a
full-on movie like people could come and
watch it like it's long as you're
playing it the right way and this one
feels exactly the same and of course
it's not playstation code yeah the best
engines like possibly run this because
as much as I love cinematic clips I love
it when the gameplay itself feels like
you're part of a cinema
now what I feel like this provides that
at one point in time I was trying to
look at hard at what part was like the
cinematic effect or what your answers
are yeah and when they always do put
those like a triangle
cuz I get to the next part they always
do make it to where it is a clip but
this one I mean I do a lot of scenes
like that it'll just feel like a full
unit just a flow movie code if you're
playing the mission yeah I've been
playing spider-man game since n64
I played the ones you just mentioned the
Tobii war once where inspire me to
you're doing the pizza-delivery stuff
and and all that and then the I actually
I love the amazing spider-man games
where Glee with San Rico was the voice I
like they got to voice a Peter Parker
spider-man in this I think it's Yuri
Lowenthal his name yeah voice actor but
I liked his name he brought that the
comedic a timing in the joke penis that
you went over well yeah yeah spider-man
just like when he joined his joke eNOS
is you know like he doesn't battling's
like he's about to die he's just like
hey next trip to Newark or whatever he
said like I love that and again the
graphics are incredible I love the way
like it like he said if Wendy did a
couple games I was thinking I was
thinking like uncharted I was thinking
some Batman Arkham stuff and now some of
the bowels of predator mode and that's
saying they're copying but just like
blending it in a good way paying homage
and saying hey we're doing our own spin
on that type of game a combat mode
because like when he was doing the
spider net was like he's moving like a
spider yeah the thing I thought about
what with the combat - it's like when I
played the Arkham games and regardless
those the mechanics are so good on that
remain Batman's would like have a hit
and then he was slide over to the map
and hit this gun when you see it happen
with fire man you actually feel like
these twists and all these going chumps
but actually like he would actually do
it actually where they like that that
was just some of the greatest I mean
there when you get to fighting games
like this they all do kind of feel like
the same kind of realm of attack block
counter kind of help I mean there's only
getting them better
yeah definitely feels good moment
weather so there was so much in just
this 9 minute gameplay of different
variations of game heading here because
you know of course you have like the
swinging around New Yor unning on the
wall running on the walls the stealth
mode
sweep slinging a guy up and hanging him
like in a spiderweb and then the full-on
combat mode and saving a helicopter so
much going on that you could do in this
game I can only imagine what the
entirety of these of the game is like
this really feels like you can beat
spider-man when you watch this so the
planning is that yeah like for the older
in games whenever you're doing something
that like you're saving somebody and
something crashes like it always just
crashes and blows up but this one it
seems like every single part that's
flying you have to save and like ya know
citizens get hurt and like that's just
incredible detail the only thing I want
them to add is that you could punch
citizens know if you can like bring up a
civilian technically there's got to be
like but I'm like I remember wasn't as
they made the choke over spider-man 3
video game and that was my favorite part
of that game is when you got the black
suit on and you can do crazy I'm like I
wish so when it's done that in the movie
but you can do crazy I feel like that
was my favorite part I mean we got to
see Miles Morales that we at awesome I
wonder if they're gonna including where
do you remember eventually the storyline
of the game changer for the Ultimate
Edition you get DLC miles per pass all
the DLCs are always going to be like so
many credible like games that they just
couldn't click to the main one and when
you get to play as miles and rise I feel
like they'll make a complete for a
couple of DFCS complete stories where
you go through it actually feels like
add-ons to the end that don't feel like
just regular out on oh now you have a
little bit of this map and you go do
these couple of missions like hopefully
I'll have a little storyline so you can
see to your partner miles around
adrianna stuff I just want to say this
game looks amazing the graphics are
incredible it looks like you're beat it
looks like it feels like you're
spider-man like that's the best part my
only concern in my concern is with this
with any video game I ever play how
repetitive is it going to feel like are
you like sometimes that
yeah spire making even though there's so
much fun you're having a great time like
story wise they can lack a little bit
because you're doing the same thing over
here you're doing 20 of saving the same
guy from local police you know which is
fine it's fun to say you know people
doing that but you want the story to
progress to at the same point you're
getting these amazing graphics because
jeans have come so far like guys from
when we grew up and like the story is a
very big deal to so and I like something
a who did mr. mr. negative in there and
they had Miles Morales oh I hope that's
all infused in GFO storyline with Wilson
says you know no that totally a great
point because I feel like that's what's
made the Batman games and if there's an
ADC comparing to Marvel this is a
superhero video game comparison I'm
making here because the Batman games
they seem to last so long because the
stories of gripping yeah and I feel like
with awesome gameplay like this if you
can get a great story in here this could
be like the I don't know marvel to have
a video game like how DC has their
Batman games that are so special with
them I feel like Marvel could have the
spider-man games at the separately what
it is whenever it comes to like if it's
Batman there will knows like everyone's
always been on the spider-man game yeah
or like that but that's whatever I gave
to them like based off the movie which
makes it tougher there's to be its own
thing and I like to have that
specialties of Miles Morales it does
make me go will this one have a much
better storyline infuse that's something
that all that fans can truly latch on to
and be around for like a franchise of
the spider-man video game and also like
you just said it's not connected to any
movie they can do whatever they want no
like they can sort of fix are coming in
I love yeah that's like the
possibilities are endless you can do
what they do in the comics where what
happens to Peter and then Miles Morales
takes over is the the mantle spider-man
so I mean again like the freedom is
there so I love that it's not connected
to anything doesn't have to worry about
movie plot lines or whatever so I yeah
I'm really hoping it turns into a great
story on top of these amazing graphics
you said that it feels like you're
spider-man watching this and like some
of the cool stuff is when you go first
up what was droving yeah hyo-jin you're
seeing him dude like now I'm still down
to r2 el tor ooh I said it a couple
times while we were watching it but I
know Anna Mae in the facial expression
like I love that yeah really cool I mean
that suit was pretty sick too
yeah I'm hoping this game gets a
positive feedback end because I do agree
with it that's the one thing of why I
never found myself like invested in
completing a lot of the spider-man games
yeah cuz it's always starts off great
it's always really cool it's always
really fun with a storyline this seems
more like I just keep Tuesday bunch of
random missions I think I should I felt
like I now then eventually get back on
the main storyline but most of us is
like teaches at a bunch of random
missions here I'm like we could have a
very specific storyline this could be a
huge video game franchise all right cool
that was fun that was an awesome trailer
kind of little bit subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification build
tree be on Instagram most importantly
follow him at it's in the gamer on
switch Andrew a Gore 7-eleven on Twitter
most importantly call him at the movie
source channel on YouTube thank you guys
become a part of the reject nature